Hi everyone.
I'm in Australia and New Zealand off to
New Zealand in the next couple of days
and I thought I'd bring you up to date
with a story that's been breaking there
that's of some substantial interest
in a certain degree of absurdity.
A group they're known as Auckland Peace
Action released a press release on
Monday 11th of February,
2019 stating quote Jordan
Peterson threatens everything
of value in our society,
which I had to admit was rather impressive
because that's not an easy thing to
manage. Anyways, I'll read
you a little bit of it.
What happened after the release was that
a journalist Sean Plunkett interviewed
the author or the spokesperson of this
particular press release and then we had
a chance to talk the next day.
And so what you're going to see in this
video is me reading the press release.
Then you're going to see
Sean interviewing iris,
Quiznos Yak hope I've got that
reasonably right of Oakland peace action.
And then you're going to see the full
interview that I had with Sean the next
day.
So here goes Jordan.
Peterson threatens everything
of value in our society.
In the lead up to Jordan
Peterson's visit to New Zealand,
we have a duty to condemn his
sexist, queer, phobic, racist,
and deeply reactionary views.
Says Iris [inaudible] of
Oakland Peace Auction.
Jordan Peterson, professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto,
turned right wing media celebrity is
in New Zealand to promote his book.
12 rules for life.
This book,
while offering superficially useful life
advice to an audience of disaffected
white men,
promotes the reactionary misogynistic
view of the world utterly in opposition to
New Zealand values. Well, we as
a country have many problems.
We can be justly proud of our
values of gender equality,
egalitarianism and social inclusivity
says Ms Krizia's Houk Jordan Peterson is
actively trying to undermine these values.
This is distinctly unhelpful.
Um,
I won't Redo the rest of it.
You can find it at scoop
politics if you're interested.
And now we'll turn to Shaun's interview
with Iris and his analysis of her
claims.
The Iris, your group has come out
with a press release yesterday.
They got some coverage and sang Jordan
Peterson threatens everything of value
and our society.
Why?
Why does telling kids to clean their
room up represent the end of civilization
as we know,
telling kids to clean their room
is probably not a bad thing.
It's true. Comes subset of, you know,
are pretty fast from old
Jordan Peterson was doing.
Not really,
that's what this book's about.
That's what he's promoting on us too.
I would say not a few can.
Like,
I mean if you take a look at some of
what's actually said in the book and in
many of a media comments
he's made elsewhere,
it seems quite clear that he has
some seriously problematic of yours.
Okay.
So let's see.
Let's begin with the kind of surface
interview with Camille Paglia. Um,
we're in heat a six of what?
Seed? Seed first. Well, you know,
he believes that and discussions
with me and he knows how to,
he knows where he stands.
More waste because
kinds of guests of honor or something.
It's Blacksburg refer to physical thoughts
can put,
uh,
may not be putting barriers around social
interaction between each other because
there's the implicit and underlying
reality that if things get out of control
with me and have a conversation,
there was the possibility of physical
violence and he sees that subconscious
check on how far or how if you like
bitchy a conversation can get these team
could by that knowledge I don't see
does does that vary suggestion or idea,
which I know a lot of people agree with.
Does that threaten Western civilization
and the very foundations in everything
of value in our society?
Well, can I just speak about wish I
weren't sick it off western civilization,
but if you consider something like say,
I mean consider basically
how that's going,
how that kind of statement
is going to be raped.
No, I think it's going to be
read by me and saying, yeah,
we need to think about
denying the differences,
the biological and I guess behavioral
differences between sexes and we need to
talk about these things honestly and
openly if we're going to make progress on
some of the issues of
gender in our society.
All right,
but on the Cultural Mueller where frankly,
homosexuals are still getting beaten up,
we have ridiculous rates of
domestic partner violence. Franklin
just want to check
you have a beaten his wife
or beaten up a homosexual?
No.
Has he ever advocated people beat
their wives will beat homosexuals?
I don't believe he has.
No. Okay, so that'd be a nine right?
Can I please,
can I please continue?
Yeah.
The effect of the allows platform,
there are many people paying
attention to him. Yeah.
If you're making statements
and social situation,
it was vitally important that you kind of,
that's the statements you make cannot be
misread and in such a way as to promote.
I would say, look, everyone's made you,
everyone has made kind of,
if you don't,
if you do it repeatedly,
that's all he does.
Or do you think he may be?
He should be shut down.
Do you think his ideas are too dangerous
and he shouldn't be allowed to speak in
New Zealand?
The leafy should be shops down.
Here's why we're not doing
the issue.
How is that his ideas,
his ideas are rather more
problematic thing. I feel your pain,
which, which ideas? Which
ones specifically that you
should clean your room.
That you should hold your shoulders back.
That you should take
responsibility for your own life.
That people shouldn't be compelled
by governments to use words,
particular words in
particular circumstances.
Okay, but one of those particular
words in particular circumstances. Yes,
I agree with it.
It'd be ridiculous to make some government
to force effectively took you use
government excuse for free,
some governmental force to do that
are being read in the media,
including by some people.
Yeah.
Well he can't be responsible
for the stupidity of people
reading the statements.
Kenny,
again, as I was saying, so do you think
that still are not responsible for,
do you think that,
do you feel that people are never
responsible for where your fixes or things
like that?
Well, yeah. No, not particularly.
But I'd also say that it would seem to
me from my observation is the impact that
Jordan Peterson has had on people's lives.
That has been overwhelmingly
positive for a huge number of people,
which is why it's so incredibly popular.
I would point to out so she can say the
same thing about a lot of special smoke
from if they have a very positive
effect on the lives of many.
Are you saying that he's a fascist?
No,
I'm not saying I am saying I am saying
but he's exploiting all the same kind of
basis.
No exposing anything.
He doesn't compel anyone to go to his
talks to look at his stuff on youtube.
How's it exploiting anyone?
I'm not saying, I mean exploiting in
terms of he is using the same chip.
Like he is using the
same basic psychological
mechanisms to build his base.
Well what base?
He's just saying what he thinks
and people happen to be interested.
I used to just thinking he's running some
campaign to destroy the Western world.
Hardly.
I just think that he is a
very irresponsible man who is,
well, let's talk about, let's
talk about responsibility.
Shall we and your group or can p section.
Um,
you would like people to go and see sit
and films and you're happy to physically
into say to stop them
seeing certain films.
And in fact your Wellington branch bought
fake bombs to create a terror at in
2018 at a film festival and stopped people
watching a film about being Gary and
right.
Is that right,
iris?
Correct.
So you're putting a very negative,
well, let's just faked, I was
just saying some facts, ma'am.
So what do you think is a
greater threat to our society?
Threatening to plant fake bombs in a movie
theater and telling people they can't
go and see a movie because
your group doesn't like it.
Do you think that's a greater threat
to our society than Jordan Peterson?
Book out a horn, say pay some money
and come and see me. If you want
Jordan piece,
so certainly create a free society.
I can tell you that I've got like I can
tell you that what you're saying about
trans people,
those queer people about a woman.
I've never seen him say
anything negative about women,
trans people or Queer people.
I've never seen them be homophobic
or misogynistic. And I believe me,
I've watched a lot of what
Jordan Peterson says and does.
I've never once anywhere
seen him being misogynistic,
homophobic,
or transphobic.
Can you point me to an
example where he has been
rs?
What do you mean by in this case,
do you mean by an example?
We an example where he in any way is
misogynistic, homophobic or transphobic.
So you do not feel that kind of say
you do not feel that effectively saying
you do. Just to be clear, you
don't feel that same with women,
a woman we lipsticks to work in
order to a sexually provocative.
He's not saying that. He's never
said that. What do you see the Iris,
what do you see it? Irises if
we need to, if we except Eh,
we've got to have some rules. He
understands the biology of men and women.
And he says, uh, main need to respect
women's boundaries. And he is always very,
very clear about that.
But he says,
if we're going to have a
d sexualized workplace,
if we're going to have a seat of rules,
let's be very clear about what those rules
are. He would argue that my cap, right,
that my cap is designed as a sexual
display in its pure, in, in a,
in an academic sense,
people put on on makeup or
have traditionally put on
makeup as a sexual display.
And he said,
okay,
if we're going to have workplaces where
six and any sort of sort of interaction
of that nature between the gin, the,
the gene does is off the agenda.
Maybe we need to think about makeup in
the workplace. He is not accusing woman,
he's not slapped shaming and
he's not sitting there saying,
woman bring it on themselves.
He's just,
we need to be realistic about
what the rules and boundaries are.
Okay,
so a question for you if you will.
So Jordan Peterson,
Jordan Peterson,
which clearly I have, which you clearly
feel are, you know, are not problematic.
Well,
no millions of people think is not
problematic and millions of people think,
seem to think he's saying stuff that
no one's had the balls to say for for a
while and they're on board with them.
No one set of both to say
is really pretty passe,
isn't it? That's what I'd say. Your
movement prides itself on doing. Hmm.
Yes. But we aren't saying
it simply to, you know,
because no one else has
the balls to say it.
We say it's because we generate genuinely
believe in our political positions
and I'm sure that that Jordan
Peterson genuinely believes in his,
and actually to be honest,
they seem more strip mainstreaming and
less of a threat to society than buying
fake bombs to scare people out of
going to see a movie in New Zealand.
Just out of curiosity,
how do you feel about,
say I didn't know are bombing
civilians have on society?
Because the is what we're
fundamentally apart.
Okay. Does, does, are you saying
Jordan Peterson bomb civilians?
No, I'm not. What I'm saying.
The why when we're talking about your
press release about Jordan Peterson.
What'd you bring that up?
Well why do you keep on
bringing up stuff about toe?
Cause it's your group that put out the
press release and it's your group that
bought fake bombs and said that people
shouldn't go and see a movie you didn't
like in a free country.
Well
like if you're going to
iris,
I might just be suggesting that your
press releases a little bit over the top.
Are you prepared to admit that
on the back of this interview?
No, simply because I simply, because
I'm living kind of on a daily,
daily,
on a fairly regular basis,
what's the Georgian peace talks
are having on his fan base.
We are getting repeated consistent
harassment from rebel from frankly Jordan,
from Jordan Peterson fans.
Because if I say sorry,
so Jordan Peterson.
Yes.
Give me an example.
Okay. Source the person
really swift. Frankly,
we uh,
look,
we got an email from him from frankly
what appears to be a white nationalist.
Yeah. We take a look at this. This if
we take a look at a whole bunch of, oh,
frankly,
not the videos.
Yeah. Peterson Nazi videos. No. No.
Okay. So what's he gonna do
with that email from the Nazi?
Well, the fact of the matter is that his
fan base, I was saying fan base thing.
I did not, I'm part of his
fan base. I'm not a Nazi.
I'm not suggesting that you are.
What would you suggest to anyone who is
does like what he sees is a Nazi? No,
that seems pretty wild.
What I am suggesting is
what he has created certain
certain subset of the fence,
which may not be the same subset of the
Europe, so I'm pretty sure they ams. Yes.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
It's behaving in,
it's behaving and frankly quite discreet.
Does the subset of his fans that represent
the threat to everything of value in
our society, not Jordan Peterson. Right.
Okay.
Right. But you can say, why didn't
you say that in your press release?
It was Jordan Peterson.
He represented the three to
everything of value in our society
because the Jordan Peterson was
calling for us tends to coalesce.
He is encouraging.
Oh he's not,
he's just saying what he thinks.
All right,
so just out of curiosity or I just got to,
where do you draw the line as to what?
Like where do you draw the line as to
responsibility for what you've said?
So yeah, I mean surely you
can't say, look you can't say,
but he'll absolutely no responsibility
for the behavior of people who um,
effectively the behavior of
people who listen to them and
well I'd be more,
I'd be more worried about the consequences
of buying a fake bomb to scare
someone out of a movie
theater to be honest. Ours
and I had decided,
I think nice nicely on this word as well.
Look,
I think we can all agree that vest,
that fet action was soulless
and first we are not like,
and as a result of that you'll notice
that we have not done that again.
Jordan Peterson on Barbara hand handles
only doubling down on his positions.
Yeah.
Many more resources.
A much wider base of support.
Yeah. Are you going to visit here and
try and, and protest outside his talk?
Any number of things?
These are things to be doing
line or are you going to plan fighting
foams? The places he speaking.
Okay.
That's just unfair.
Oh, okay. Wow.
We've done it once.
I've clearly stated sort of towards a
bad idea and if we don't some teams to
repeat tips.
Okay.
Well RSRs yeah,
as far as we're concerned.
So best thing we can do in order to,
the best thing we can do in
order to counteract speak,
just to make people aware
of what his views are.
What are you said and
how else fan base behaves
and all these views are very reasonable
and seem to be having a positive effect
on the massive number of people who were
saying IRS. Well cause it's the truth.
Iris,
I thank you for your time.
That's Iris Christianne
of Oakland Pace Action.
So that's that.
The Auckland Peace Action
Group did release it.
Another press release on the 14th stating
Auckland Peace Action is issuing a
statement to publicly correct the record
about a protest action that occurred
in Wellington in 2018 there's action
occurred at the screening of the film,
Ben Gurion at the dark edge film festival,
both Oakland Peace Action and our sister
organization Peace Action Wellington
opposed to showing of this film as it is
subject to an international boycott on
behalf of Palestinian civil society
organizations at both Wellington and
Auckland screenings.
The screenings were disrupted by
activists with noisemakers and alarms.
Subsequently,
the dark edge director alleged that
there was a fake bomb at the Wellington
screening and this was reported by
new hub. This was a complete lie.
There was never,
ever any fake bomb of any sort whatsoever,
and z police attended both protests and
we're fully aware that the items in the
theaters were noisemakers
as we're the theater goers.
The theater was not evacuated
and no one was arrested.
So it appears that at least as far as
Auckland peace action is concerned that
Sean overstated the case in that lecture.
In any case the next day I had a
chance to talk to him directly.
And so now we're going to
segue directly into that.
Your face. Let's get the pronouns out
of the way. What would you prefer?
I call you professor, Dr. Jordan.
Jordan's spine. Jordan's fine.
I like it that way as well. Um, Jordan,
my first question for you and the
reaction here in New Zealand, um,
to the very idea that you're coming here
or that you're fronting on this show
today. I just got to say, and I've
watched you for a couple of years,
you are one of the most
hated people online.
Why do you think it is
that while people hate you?
I'm hated by a very small minority
of very noisy and committed people.
Yeah. And so, um,
they're noisy and committed and so they
can make a lot of racket and they are
very good at it and often the profit
often professionally trained to do so.
And they're very casual with there. What
would you call it? Epithets. I mean,
I was listening to you introduced me
and you, you listed off about 20, um,
terrible things that I might be
many of which were contradictory,
but that doesn't seem
to make any difference.
Well,
it's so hilarious you,
you kind of get your celebrity gets co
opted from people on all sorts of parts
of the political and extremes of
the political spectrum, doesn't it?
Well, I think there's some of that. Um,
I don't know if it gets co-opted too
much on the radical left, let's say.
Although I certainly face the majority
of my opposition from the radical left,
but the radical right types
are not very fond of me either.
There was a new book written called
Dianetics by a rather reprehensible
individual named Fox Day.
And if you want to find out what the
ethno nationalists think about me,
that's pretty good read. I wouldn't
call it precisely complimentary.
Hmm.
Look on a personal level,
and I'm someone who has fallen foul
of the vagaries of Twitter pylons,
but what's directed at you? Is it
a whole different level, Jordan?
And you've admitted, I know that
you have or not struggled, but you,
you admit your, you've had episodes
of depression in your life.
I know people who have been horribly
affected by the most minor pylon on social
media.
How do you as an individual
take or channel that hatred
to Gooden and I imagined
that affects your family as well?
Well, part of it is that I have
a pretty solid family. You know,
I have lots of people behind me,
like my wife is firmly behind
me without hesitation. Um,
my children are behind me and they're
smart and mature and my parents are behind
me and I have a good
set of friends. And, um,
also generally I try not to talk
about things that I don't know.
Something about which also
helps. Yeah. So, and I'm,
I'm not impressed with the sorts of
ideological positions that have been put
forth, especially by the left wing
radical types in the universities.
And I understand what they're
doing and why reasonably well. And,
um,
I feel that whatever vitriol happens to
be directed at me is trivial in terms of
its danger in comparison
to the overwhelming social
danger that these ideologies
are producing. And so better to do
something about it now than to wait.
Hmm. Oh, so, and I,
social media world that is dominated
by extremism and hatred and vitriol,
uh, people I know who
have have watched you, uh,
literally dumbstruck by your ability
to remain civil and to engage in debate
without getting angry at those who,
who often absolutely lambasted you.
I think I've only seen there was a debate
you did with Stephen Fry where, uh,
an American pastor had to go and
I think I saw some five there.
I think you were genuinely upset,
but you seem to have a remarkable,
remarkable ability to play the ball,
not the man or woman.
Well, that, that debate the monk
debate that you're talking about.
Mostly I was upset about the
foolishness, you know, um, the,
the person I was debating with Cole called
me an angry white and it just struck
me as so,
so rhetorically foolish and
inflammatory and unnecessary.
All of those things at the
same time. Uh, first of all,
he was in Canada and not
in the United States.
And those sorts of statements actually
don't go over very well in Canada.
And my race had absolutely nothing to
do with what we were talking about.
And so it was just the kind
of troublemaking statement
that does nothing but
make things worse.
And I'm never happy when I see people
behaving in a manner that only makes
things worse. And so
that, that I felt even,
it's a funny thing,
I can't say exactly felt bad for him,
but I thought it was so foolish of him
to undermine his own credibility in that
manner.
It was just this sort of performance
that removes all patients,
you know, a bad rhetorical statement
and unnecessary racist comment,
a rhetorical flourish that had nothing
but counterproductive consequences.
As you can see by the youtube commentary,
added nothing at all that
was productive to the debate,
didn't address the issues at hand,
was a cheap method of scoring
points, uh, a way of playing victim.
I mean, it was all together. Um, uh, uh,
second grade performance.
And,
and because he had academic
pretensions was a professor.
I have a lot less patience for professors
and professional journalists than I do
for, you know, other people because, well,
because they're, they're supposed to,
well that's,
I thought Stephen Fry was brilliant
in that debate. I used to,
man started outside. You didn't
agree with a lot of what you said,
but he was going to stand next year and
fight your side. And he also said I'm,
the world would be a much better place
if everyone was less convinced of how
right they were.
Yeah.
Well Steven Fry is really something,
it was a pleasure to meet him and he's uh,
he's quite the remarkable person.
So that was one of the very
good things about that evening.
Hmm. We're going to take a bright Jordan
and then I want to talk to you about an
interview I did yesterday and if that's
typical of the stuff that you get.
Yeah, that was great. The interview
man, we would talk to Jordan B.
Peterson here on magic talk back and just
to see, and we would talk to Jordan B.
Peterson cultural phenomenon.
And according to Oakland Peace Action.
The biggest threat to New Zealand's
way of life and civilization that, oh,
I don't know. We've seen
since the last earthquake. Uh,
they came out earlier this week
and through a lot of labels, uh,
at Dr. Peterson and the spokesman,
Iris or spokesperson Iris came on
with me yesterday, some of these,
so I could ask them to well provide
the proof of their accusations.
Um, I didn't think he did that
well or they did that well, Jordan.
Uh, well it was quite the remarkable
interview. I think that, uh,
I don't know how many people have
watched it or listened to it,
but I suspect quite a few and it's
no wonder because it was, it was, um,
a real feat of journalistic persistence,
I would say on your part,
you didn't let your,
your interviewee off the hook for a moment
and there wasn't much content there.
There was a lot of exactly the same sort
of thing that's been happening for the
last two years.
It's really quite appalling.
And that what seems to happen generally
in the journalistic sphere on the
negative side for me is that
there's a list of epithets that are,
it's like all the radical leftists have
a list of epithets that are sort of add
hand. Maybe they have them on a little
sticky on their computer, misogynist,
homophobe, Islamophobe
transphobes a bigot, racist. Uh,
then there's often some
either Nazi, uh, uh,
Oh,
don't forget you
location [inaudible] or
there's Jewish shill,
which is another one that comes
up now and then, and then, um,
the idea seems to be that if you don't
agree with what someone says that you
just lay out the longest possible list
of Pejorative, that your imagination,
your collective imagination can
generate and hope that one of them is
sufficiently true in some sense because
of something you once said that it
sticks and you're done. And it's,
it's getting downright Dell. I mean,
but what seems to be that
liberal journalists throughout
the Western world have
been lining up to try and take you down?
Oh yeah. Well, I mean,
I've had a fair number of journalists
who've been supportive, supportive of me.
Now, whether or not they
are on the liberal side,
there's certainly not on the
radical left side. Um, yes,
this has been happening pretty
much nonstop for two years. Um,
and they're basically out of
insults as far as I can tell,
which in some sense disarms them,
but they're actually getting rather dull
to read because it's always the same
old thing.
Ang,
although the person you interviewed
yesterday did have a new twist,
which was greatest threat to
the civilization of New Zealand,
which was really quite impressive
as far as pejorative went.
Alright.
So we've dealt with,
and now you're in Australia now has the,
if you like,
the virulent opposition to
you for whatever reason,
is it starting to subside?
And I know they haven't been protest
as I understand so far in Australia.
Uh, there was a few in Adelaide,
but, uh, about 25 and, and,
and they, it wasn't exactly clear
what they were protesting. Um,
they seem to be more, uh,
concerned about homosexual rights,
um, which I don't really know
what that has to do with me,
but it had to do with whatever they
were interested in. Uh, protesting,
but there was nothing in
Melbourne at all though.
There was quite a large
police presence at the venue.
While there were a lot of people there,
there's about 5,500 people,
but there wasn't a single protester. And
I would say that yes, overall, the, um,
very elance and also the frequency
of the hip pieces in the media is,
has declined rather precipitously in
the last three or four months. Um,
I think it's because,
well,
because it's become dreadfully repetitious
and because no smoking pistol of any
sort has emerged,
you know,
people have gone over virtually everything
I've said to students for the last 20
years because almost all of it is recorded
and scoured my Twitter feed and my
Facebook and you know,
all this social media, um,
platforms that are usable and haven't
been able to find anything so far that's
of sufficient reprehensive bility to,
um,
take my reputation out
the dots so that we have Jordan come on.
Well, it's not just a bit
weird. It's very weird,
but you know,
it's not something I,
let's say.
Alright.
Um,
I want to go back two years and in many
ways I look at you and if I was going to
put you in a fibril, you're the guy
who said the emperor has no clothes,
the emperor of wokeness of political
correctness of third wave feminism.
Did you plan two years ago
to be where you are now?
I cultural phenomena,
global cultural phenomenon.
Was it all part of some,
some clever manipulation
of modern social media?
Or did you just stand up and say,
I'm not going to do this?
Well,
I mean, I was writing a book and I
was hoping it would be successful.
So there was that.
And you know,
I had been experimenting quite
substantially with, um, with, uh,
youtube,
putting my,
my lectures from the university on Youtube
and some lectures that I had done for
a small television show and they
were developing a certain following.
So I had about a million views Po far
before the political controversy hit.
But no, I mean, there's no way
of predicting what happened.
It's completely unpredictable phenomenon.
But a phenomenon,
but I can't say that I said what I felt
like saying as carefully as I possibly
could and I'd pretty much had
enough of it. I mean, seriously,
I've had enough of it and,
um,
I'm not happy with the radical leftists.
I think the postmodern philosophy is,
um,
what intellectually Vapid,
nihilistic, malevolent,
destructive, arrogant and
narcissistic, impractical as well.
All at the same time.
I think that what's happening to the
humanities and social sciences is borders
on fraudulently criminal.
If it hasn't already passed the line.
And I'm absolutely no friend whatsoever
of radical leftist utopians I feel that
there's,
after a hundred years of evidence of
complete bloody catastrophe on the side of
the radical left,
um,
it's time for us to wake up and notice
that something has gone wrong on that end
of the spectrum.
And I don't see any responsibility
being taken for that at all. You know,
I've called publicly for the moderate
leftist types who might have some sympathy
for, to draw some lines.
It's like, all right,
we know that things can go too far
on the left when exactly where,
where is it that you go too far?
Now my sense it's with the equity
doctrine, which I think is, um,
not really emotionally powerful.
Unfortunately. It doesn't have that,
that kick that's necessary to make
something really stick in the memory.
But I think the idea of
equality of outcome is, um,
dangerous beyond comprehension.
Oh, Ron, I want to talk about a few
things going on in New Zealand, which is,
you know,
part of the culture war.
We are part of the global
community and we connected online.
A fist up we have a cabinet,
um, the Labor Party, uh,
the largest member of a part of our
coalition government. It has a quota,
a male female quota for cabinet posts.
What Canada too. Yeah.
What do you think of that?
All right, thanks. I think there's
absolutely no excuse for it.
I think that it's an, it's
a, you know, the, the,
the radical leftists are always yammering
on about biological essentialism,
which they are so associated with
something it can to fascism. You know,
the idea that there are mutable biological
characteristics that define people
and yet they're the first people to
insist that if you're going to have a
cabinet that is let's say both
competent and representative,
that you have to divide it
according to identity categories.
And first and foremost,
perhaps the ones of sex and,
and to pick your cabinet by Genitalia
is not an acceptable technical move.
And exactly the same thing happened in
Canada where 25% of our major parties,
elected officials who are female,
but 50% of the cabinet members
or members ended up being female.
And all that means what that certainly
means is that the [inaudible],
the most qualified people were not
selected because it's statistically
impossible for them to have been selected.
It was cheap virtue signaling.
And,
and it's also technically impossible
even from the perspective of the leftist
themselves with their intersectionality
because they insist that people have to
be judged in relationship to their
oppression on multiple dimensions
simultaneously.
And I've done some back of the envelope
mathematical calculations and if you
have 10 dimensions that mark you out,
let's say as in terms of your,
of the group affiliations
that characterize you,
then you're the only person like
that the world. So as you multiply,
all you have to do is do the math as you
multiply the number of groups that have
to be given favored status because if
there hypothetically oppressed situation,
then you make it increasingly impossible
for equality of outcome to even be to,
to, to be something that can
be practically implemented
without a bureaucracy of,
of terrifying proportions.
We also have a ministry of Women's
affairs in New Zealand and the Minister of
women's of feasible,
the minister for a woman is,
she's known suggested recently that they
were too many white old men on boards
in New Zealand,
the private and public companies and
just suggested that they needed to move
aside so there could be more diversity.
Your response to that suggestion?
Well, um, what, what's her racial
and ethnic background just out of
hear you? I think she's born
in America. Julianne. Gina.
She's a member of green potty. Yeah.
Is she white? Yes. Well maybe it,
it's time for her to bloody well move
aside and let someone who isn't white have
her position.
All right,
so you've done a great job
with Julianne Jeans. Instance.
There's also, look, they've tried this
in Scandinavia where they put, you know,
they've put quotas for females on boards
and part of the idea was that if you
did that that you would increase the
rate at which women would move through
managerial and administrative status
rankings and that has had zero success.
This suggestion also is Jordan,
that actually women can somehow um,
up the financial performance
of companies sure.
That you don't believe
they'd stats that resonance.
No evidence for that. What, what,
what elevates the financial, uh,
productivity of companies is quite clear.
Trait conscientiousness,
which is a marker for integrity
and trustworthiness and diligence,
diligence and due to fullness is a very
good predictor of long term economic
productivity.
And so his general cognitive ability
and that holds across sexes and races.
And the reason for that,
and this is the non racist and nonsexist
way of looking at the world by the way,
is that there is far more dif difference
between individuals within groups than
there are between groups. Because
look, the fundamental racist,
sexist,
uh,
ethnocentric proposition is that there
are more differences between groups of
people then there are within
groups of people. Yeah.
That's essentially the racist doctorate.
Yeah.
And so we need some black
people because you know,
all those black people are the same.
And unless we have a voice
or two from a black person,
then we don't have that set of
identity issues represent it.
Well,
it's just simply not the case because
most of the diversity comes at the level
of individual personality and temperament.
And the literature on that is crystal
clear. You know, these, these,
these are pseudo intellectual claims
made by people on the radical left and
they're very dangerous because they're
easily shifted into the sorts of things
that the radical right likes
to enjoy, which is, oh, I see.
There are immutable differences between
Gen the sexist and the races and there
are substantial import.
And that we, we, we,
we, we are, we need to take them
into account when we're, uh,
uh, what, what,
what would you just say formulating such
things as immigration policy. So no,
there's no evidence that
those claims are correct and,
and there's counter evidence for much of
it for so example in, in Scandinavian,
and this is,
this is as close to psychological factors,
any thoughts that exist is that as
you increase equality of opportunity,
which means you open the doors for more
and more people and especially in let's
say with regards to sex. Um, and,
and that's had a big effect because of
course there's far more women in the
workforce than there than there once was.
You increase the degree to which
outcomes differ on multiple dimensions.
And that's partly, there's a variety
of reasons for that. At least a dozen.
And they're all important,
one of which is that women,
especially once they hit their
thirties prefer to work part time.
And that's not bad or wrong.
And it's certainly not an
indication of systemic sexism.
So the radical types like
to have one explanation.
Everyone isn't exactly the
same with regards to outcome.
Therefore the system is
a corrupt patriarchy.
It's like you can learn
that in one minute in a,
in a propaganda course in university
and then you have an answer for every
problem that ever be,
sets you politically for the rest of
your life and there's no excuse for it.
It's appalling scholarship.
I want to come back to that point.
The other thing, Bill proposed,
bill we hit before at parliament is the
idea of six self identification to make
it easier for people to alter their
birth certificates if they choose to
identify as anything other
than the sex they were born as.
You'll views on on that
sort of legislation.
Well,
the first thing I would say,
it might be useful to really
address some important problems.
That would be the first thing is you're
dealing with an absolutely tiny minority
of people.
Not that that's completely without import.
But the second thing is it has to be
thought through and it's not, I mean,
I don't know if you've been following,
oh,
we just having a little hiccup there
and we're talking to Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson, who's joining us
from Scott, from Sydney,
Jordan. We were talking about,
so six self od did vacation, uh, changes
or proposed reforms in New Zealand.
You see it firstly,
it's a number
of people affected and seeking.
Did you say we need to think it through?
In what way? Well, one of the
things that's happened for example,
so really what this is,
is an attempt by a certain
ideological movement too,
to put forth the insistence that sex
is only a sociological construct,
that it's only something learned and
so that it can be changed at whim,
which is also a strange thing
because if it's learned,
it can't really be changed at whim.
And also if it's learned,
it could be unlearned,
which is something that the people who
are putting this legislation forward
aren't really thinking through because
that opens up the opportunity for people
who would like to reform people who
would like to change their gender back to
say normative behavior. Because if
it's learned, it can be unlearned.
But more importantly,
sex roles are not only learned there,
partly learned and there's plenty of
biological differences between men and
women and,
and many of them aren't trivial,
like men and women are more the
same than they are different.
But the differences are
quite market at the extremes.
And so what we're seeing partly as a
consequence of this now is the movement of
say Trans Women into female sports. You
saw this in Minnesota just the other day,
I think it was Minnesota where I knew Lee,
um,
transition trans woman has been shattering
the weightlifting records for women
and Commonwealth Games competitor.
It was a form of mind. Yes,
it's absolutely insane. You know, I mean,
first the fact that it's allowed to
begin with is beyond comprehension.
It's a real sign of cultural insanity.
And the second is that psychologically
it's almost incomprehensible.
I can't imagine how you could be a man
who transformed himself into a woman and
all the ways that that's possible.
And then decided to go compete in it
at a high level sports arena with women
who've been training their whole lives
to hit the peak of their ability and then
to absolutely bloody demolish them,
say after a year of work.
And then to tout that as some
sort of victory for the oppressed.
It's completely what's narcissistic
beyond comprehension. And it's,
it's, it's, well,
it's a sign of what happens when you
don't carefully think things through.
All sorts of unexpected consequences
tend to manifest themselves.
And you'll see the same thing happening
now with rapid onset gender dysphoria
and the treatment of very young people
with very powerful hormonal and surgical
techniques designed to permanently alter
their psychophysiological structure.
And like,
we're going to pay for this in a big way
in 15 years when these kids grow up and
hit adulthood and start tossing out
lawsuits as they certainly will.
And should we're,
we're going to look back and wonder just
exactly what the hell was wrong with us.
So it's, it's, it's, it's, well,
it's driven by this ideology that that's
been formulated by people like Judith
Butler who absolutely insist because
they have no biological knowledge,
which whatsoever that all the differences
between men and women are socially
constructed,
which is absolutely not true.
Absolutely. In general terms, Jordan,
and we have it in this country and indeed
everywhere we look at the millennial
generation, they get a bit of
stick here. The cold snow flakes,
they seem to get outraged not on the,
on their own behalf,
but on behalf of others
at the drop of a hat.
And they use social media as elsewhere
in the world to call out the things they
find offensive or the feelings.
Do you think there is a
collective generational
psychosis occurring because of
social media?
Um,
I don't know if the millennial
generation is any less sane than the baby
boomers.
I mean the baby boomers had plenty of
trouble and they cost plenty of grief and
misery in the 1960s and experimented,
you know,
crazily with psychedelic drugs and a wild
lifestyle and promiscuous sex and all
of those things.
And I don't think that the millennials
are any worse or any better.
I do think that,
um,
there is a small subset of them who are
rather dependent and rather narcissistic
and who are being encouraged in both
of those by reprehensible adults in
positions of authority primarily in the
universities to make the most of their
victim hood feelings and status.
And I do think that the
social media platforms also
allow for a disproportionate
effect of social effect of people
who have extreme views that also in
combination with the,
with the increasing death of the,
of the standard collective media,
which is increasingly
desperate for attention.
And so we'll spend more and more attention
paying to people who paying spends
more and more time paying attention to
people who have extreme views on the
right end of life.
Making that
well, it's, it's possible.
Well, I bet. I mean,
I've certainly been represented as an
extreme figure and that's really something
that,
apart from the fact that I'm adamant in
my opposition to the radical leftists,
which is rather rare among intellectuals,
which brings us rather nicely,
Jordan, to what I'm talking about.
I asked people to call and use today
and it was remarkable the variety and
number of people who sent me messages and
rang and said simply reading your book
had changed their life.
And uh,
can I just put a call out if you want to
talk to Jordan, we've got quarter, hour,
hour, 808 four four, seven, four, seven.
If you'd like to ask a question or seem
the mason jar or just say something to
Jordan, you can ring in now are 808
four four, seven, four, seven Jordan,
it also seems to me,
as much as I see all the hatred against
you and the controversy around you
online,
Geez,
there's a lot of love there and there's
a lot of positivity and you seem to be
engaging and smiling
and with young people,
there's some good stuff happening here,
isn't there?
Oh yeah, way, way more
than the, like the, the,
the vitriol vitriolic aspect of it
is only a sporadic bother to me.
Um,
usually in the aftermath of a
particularly difficult interview with a
journalist, but the tour, I mean,
I've been to about 140
cities now around the world,
and the average audience size is,
well,
it's varied between 20 508,000, um, with,
I would say an average of about
2,500 to 3000. And they're,
the events are unbelievably,
yeah. Positive.
So most of the time I'm surrounded
by nothing but positive responses.
And when I go out on the
street, no, wherever I go,
you know, in a typical hour all
be stopped by six or seven people.
They're usually young men
because the media has convinced.
Yeah, I actually was going
to say yesterday we had
justice been a young woman and
middle aged women and
middle age men ringing in.
Well, that's good. I think that's changed
to some degree because of the book. But,
um,
all of the interactions that I have with
people on the street or in airports or
so on, they're all incredibly positive.
People are very polite. They come up, uh,
they're usually apologetic for
interrupting. They introduced themselves.
They tell me that watching my lectures
are listening to the audio or reading the
book has changed their life. They usually
tell me a story about what's changed.
They have a better time.
What office do that in real time right
now. Um, Jordan, say hello to Rachel.
Hello Rachel. Oh, cure to Jordan. Um,
I'm doing nervous to be talking
to you and I'm gonna not very,
very good at being precise in Westminster
and when I keep it very brief and just
say thank you as all I wanted to say.
Um,
I'm one of the people whose life has been
changed immeasurably by your book and
your lectures and everything that you
stand for has really had a massive
positive influence on me. So I just
wanted to tell you how grateful I am.
I was. So, what's changed?
Uh, it would take a very long time to get
into it, but I have struggled with, uh,
mental health issues for the
majority of my life since puberty.
I'm 30 now and I've been through
every type of treatment, counseling,
therapy, medication, everything
you can think of and you know,
things have helped me briefly for a
little while and got better and then got
worse again. But your book, um,
I guess it's the adoption of personal
responsibility more than anything. And,
and the more responsibility I take on,
the more I find I'm able to in,
the more I'm able to get myself out
there and put myself in situations I
wouldn't have normally had the confidence
to. I'm standing up straighter.
I'm not that great at
keeping my room tidy yet,
but I'm working on it a little things,
everything just bit by bit.
The more I take on, the
more, the bigger it gets.
Yes. Well that's a good rule.
That's a good rule. You know,
that's a good psychotherapeutic rule
is the more that you take on without
overloading yourself, you know, because
you have to be sensible about it.
The more you find that you have
abilities that will manifest themselves,
that had been hidden up to that point
because of fear and avoidance and so more
power to you as far as I'm concerned.
And I'm very glad to hear that what
I've been doing has been helpful.
Good on your Rachel. Mary, welcome.
Um, thank you very much for
this opportunity. I'm doctor,
I was staring into the
abyss and now I'm not.
Um, I moved through my life. It was fleet.
Consider every action and reaction,
uh,
treat myself like I'm someone,
a kid for four.
It's been a revelation
to me encountering you.
I was in a very,
very,
very top slice and somehow
I found you online.
I don't know if it was
through Dave Rubin or,
or who Shapiro or, or, um, I'm
not quite sure how it happened,
but I've seen the Ilitches have,
I'll listen to it.
You mentioned meaning your
elixirs on Genesis. Um,
and it's just been a remarkable turnaround
in my life and my family's life.
Um,
and I just want to say thank you.
Hey Man, I'm thrilled
to hear it. So do you,
do you have any sense of
what in particular did it,
like what was it that struck you?
I think it just depends on the store
way that you spoke and it was just such
plain English. It was, as
you described previously,
that was some rules are I
sort of sort of cliches,
but they hadn't been spoken
of in a very long time.
And it was as the previous coolest state,
that positional responsibility, the,
the taking care of oneself and
it just struck such a chord.
It was, I knew some of the things that
you were saying, I'd heard them before,
but I hadn't had them in a very long time.
My father used to say, yeah, I'm strike.
We just showed his bag and,
and finally there was a game,
but it was being seen in a different
way. And it, yeah, it wasn't
I why Aa, that's, that's
the thing. And that's what I
tried to do with my lectures.
And partly because I'm a
behavioral psychologist,
it's like we have all
these more rules and,
and people are told the rules,
but they're very seldom
given a multidimensional of
why the rules are necessary.
You know,
it's while you should do it because that's
what people do or that's because you
know,
that's what good people do or it's your
responsibility and all those things are
true.
But the explanation of why it's true and
how it's related to the responsibility
that gives your life meaning
and also improves the world,
your family and the community,
that's, that's often lacking.
And so that's what I was trying to
provide and in as clear and, and,
and in English, as clear as I
could manage it. And so, you know,
it, I've tried to make it practical and
useful for people and I'm really very,
very happy to hear that it's
worked for you and for your family.
I'm thrilled to hear it as I always
am when I hear a story like that. Um,
pizza joins us now.
Welcome Peter.
Well, you're doing, yeah. Hello. Um,
hello.
How are you doing Peter?
Very, very little hay. Um,
have you in a moment of self
reflection head a little bit on,
on this amazing and astounding
following you created and,
and one did where it's going to end up
because at the risk of sending oxymoronic,
you're probably the closest thing to
secular humanist. Here's to a messiah.
Well,
I thought about that.
I wouldn't say precisely
in those terms. Um, I mean,
one of the things I did learn from
studying Carl Young years ago was that if
you're going to talk about archetipal
stories, which I do all the time,
did you have to be very careful not to
confuse yourself with the archetype,
you know? And so I'm, I'm,
I'm very cognizant of the danger
of the kind of popularity that I'm
experiencing. And I do mean the
danger because the higher you fly,
the faster you can fall.
And,
and you have to be very careful to
ensure that you're not increasing the
probability of that.
Um,
I try to make sure that I credit other
people with many of the ideas that I,
I've formulated and,
and because I've learned a lot from
reading the great clinicians and,
and philosophers have the last say 150
years and from my clinical practice and
so on.
And so,
and I think of this endeavor
not as something that I'm doing,
but as something that we're
all collectively engaged
in because I know that you
know,
that there's an old idea that every person
is a center of the world and that the
weight of the world for better or worse
ways upon the shoulders of each person.
And I really believe that's true.
And so if you know that,
then it keeps the ego TISM
and the arrogance down partly
out of sheer terror and
it makes it much more
effective to deal with people.
Like when I'm lecturing in front of an
audience, I'm not lecturing to them,
you know, I'm lecturing with them,
talking about problems that we all have,
including me and aims that we all
hold, need to develop, including me.
And you have to include yourself, so
to speak, among the centers and the,
and the reprehensible types in order
to communicate with people properly.
I do my best to ensure that I'm starkly
aware of my shortcomings and false,
that every moment I can possibly manage.
And I have family and friends who also
help keep what I'm doing and check and to
make sure that it's not going sideways
in some manner. That's, you know,
where I'm taking things for granted or
becoming arrogant or any of that. And so,
so far that's worked out well and
hopefully it will continue to.
Joe,
welcome to the program.
Oh, hi Joe. Thanks for
talking with me. Uh, Jordan.
Okay.
Hi Joe.
How are you doing?
Good,
thank you.
So I'm a young academic in New
Zealand and one of the problems,
well one of the stations I would say we
haven't needed this days is focused on
race and gender.
So I'm,
I would call a centrist position,
um, somewhat liberal minded.
But what advice would you give a
young academic pushing against the,
what I see is the file if the
gender of the universities.
Well,
the first thing I would say is there a
lot more moderate types of your store
then you think.
And so if you're a careful person and
you're thinking things through and you
have things to object to,
you can be sure,
virtually sure that a majority of people
agree with you even though there are
two. Um, how loud let's say, uh,
to, to speak up. Um,
I would say get your thoughts in order,
you know, so you know what you stand for.
And then I would also say don't agree
with anything that you don't agree with
because all that'll happen. Yeah.
And you're a young academic.
All the will happen if you compromise
your intellectual Saul like increment by
increment over the next 10 years is
that you will end up alcoholic and,
and bitter,
hating your job,
despised by your undergraduates and
absolutely sick of your existence.
And it's like you gotta keep that
really firmly in mind because every time
you're called upon to stand forth
or something you believe in, it's a,
it's a test of character and courage and
it's easy to put it off because it's a
lot of trouble. You know, it's a lot of
conflict and you might think, Oh God,
do I really have to go through with this?
I've got other things to do.
And if the answer is,
well,
I better stand up for what I believe
in now because if I keep letting it go
increment by increment
for the next 10 years,
I'm going to end up in a position that
that is absolutely dreadful. You know,
you'll be much older than you need to
be and all of the thrill that should be
part of teaching young people and doing
research and staying on the cutting edge
of knowledge.
All of that will have been taken away
by the India logs who already know
everything and insist that they get
to regulate what you think and say.
So good to have the small fights.
One by one
value of the lucky last is the
coolest Jordan's split yet.
Yes.
Talk to Jordan Peterson.
You are awesome man are already
booked and we were following you.
I'm a student of psychology
philosophy myself.
I did a degree and I'm doing my
post here and a lot of what you say,
you know, there's a wee bit of
each in there and um, you know,
and I totally agree because we live
in a, sorry, where like for me,
I often say what I think and
I have to moderate there,
but particularly today in our society,
when you do that,
you're in way more trouble for
offending someone or something and all.
I love the fact that you kind of get it
out there and I wish that you know it,
it'll be handy to just didn't get it out
and people can hear and get over one.
One question I was wanting to
ask you though. I mean I'm a,
I'm a Christian, but I studied,
um, mock is, she really is,
and I read his book and I feel those
books. I, you went to stoicism.
Um,
not,
I wouldn't say specifically lots of people
who have been studying stoicism have
talked to me and suggested
that I should be.
The overlap I think is that the stoic
virtues have been radically underplayed in
our society.
Um,
because we have this idea that life is
easy and that we should be happy and
well, first of all, life isn't easy
and perhaps we should be happy.
But there's lots of times
when we're not going to,
I hate to break this up, both coming up
to the news. We've got calls stacked up.
I'm hoping to meet you when you come here
and I'd like to invite you now if you
get any spare time and you'll share
jewel to come into the studio because
literally our boards are full with
people who want to talk to you.
I also want to thank you enormously for
your time today and for assuring us that
you will not,
you know,
they to the visit will not lead to the
downfall of New Zealand's civilization as
we know it.
Well,
I hope not.
I hope not because I think you have
quite a civilization and it would,
I'd hate to be the bringer
of its downfall. So
well, hope that tap lovely
talking to you, Jordan.
Thank you very much for your time.
So I'll just end this video with the
reminder that there are still tickets left
to the 12 rules for life lecture tour,
if you'd like to see it in New Zealand
at the Michael Follower Center,
Thursday,
February 21st that's in Wellington
at the Logan Campbell Center. Saturday,
February 23rd that's in Auckland,
then back to Australia, ICC, Sydney
theater at darling Harbour. Tuesday,
February 26th in Sydney plenary,
Melbourne Convention and
Exhibition Center. Wednesday,
February 27th in
Melbourne and in Brisbane,
Brisbane Convention and Exhibition Center.
Thursday,
February 28th you can find information
about those tickets@jordanbpeterson.com.
Forward slash events.
That's Jordan B peterson.com
forward slash events.
Hope to see you there. Thank
you very much. Bye. Bye.